and let's start with cam newton patriots
quarterback speaking to w-e-e-i in
boston just a couple of days after the
team's first loss of the season but
still an impressive showing offensively
for cam newton the patriots here he is
talking about whether or not they need
to go outside the locker room in their
search for receivers
do you feel like you need
another receiver would you like to see
the patriots do something when it comes
to that position
man i'll say this the answers are in
that locker room
simply play
you know we got a little bud doughboy
highway 11
and you know my germs so
we good to go and um so oh we have to
let we never rewind that we have junior
bird
nikhil harry
dewan edelman
and jacoby myers
yeah look it's hardly a murderer's row
of receivers but the group will get
better they generated plenty of yardage
the other night when the quarterback is
playing great it doesn't matter who the
receivers are in cam newton has played
great now that doesn't mean that the
patriots aren't always looking to
upgrade because
cam newton did not sign on to become the
general manager of the patriots so it
won't be up to him if they do upgrade
but it's better than the alternative
it's better than cam newton after two
weeks shireen's saying can they please
get me some help at receiver
first of all mike i think the patriots
have more nicknames than we do at pro
football talk and we like to nickname
everybody but that was a pretty
impressive group of nick games that he
fired off there but
i would challenge anyone before you
watch that to come up with the four top
receivers for the patriots because i
don't know that i could have come up
with them off the top of my head
obviously we all know julian edelman and
nick kill harry but beyond that uh it's
sort of a stretch but this is kind of in
the patriots history right they tried a
b last year for one game it didn't work
out but generally tom brady had to work
with whatever receivers he had and he
always had one favorite julian edmond
being the latest of of his favorites uh
until he left new england until tom
brady left new england and and now it's
kind of the same thing for cam newton
yeah i would bet that he had better
receivers in carolina than he has now
but he's making it work and and they
have done great so far could be 2-0 at
this point
it really is an amazing indictment on
bill belichick's time with the patriots
when you consider how few great
receivers he has had and how guys have
just kind of fallen into his laps from
time to time and ended up being great
but last year they gave up a second
round pick to get mohamed sanu we've
advocated for a trade that would send
odo beckham jr from cleveland to new
england but that would happen later in
the year but right for now it's julian
edelman who has 236 receiving yards more
than twice nikhil harry's 111 then demir
byrd who looked good on sunday night
against seattle he has six catches for
72. the next guy on the receiving
yardage list is rex burkhead you don't
see another receiver until you get past
burkhead ryan izzo and james white all
the way down to jacoby myers with one
catch for seven yards so it is a work in
progress they are doing what they can to
make chicken salad out of a depth chart
that was one of the reasons some believe
for tom brady moving on to the tampa bay
buccaneers shireen
yeah and and kill harry talked earlier
just a little bit ago as a matter of
fact to the to the media in new england
and they were trying to get him to
compare year one to year two and you
know with where this is headed what's
the difference between tom brady and
and cam newton but he wouldn't go there
he's basically talked about his growth
you know he did not have a ultra
successful rookie season he's been much
better this year but he wouldn't say it
was cam newton he just said his growth
maturing becoming better in the offense
knowing the offense better and knowing
what defenses do better so i think
that's a big part of his growth and i
think we're going to continue to see
that throughout the year i think he's
just going to get better and better and
better as they go along
never talk about anybody on the team
other than yourself it is not your job
to evaluate the performance of your
teammates whether it's good whether it's
bad do your job do your expletive
deleted job that is the patriot way and
harry's been there long enough to know
that's what you should do never talk
about anyone else on the team
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports